i
[Música]
esta es mamá ciudad emblemática del
noreste de nigeria sus calles aún están
marcadas por los combates de septiembre
de 2014 cuando esta ciudad de 250 mil
habitantes cayó en manos de boko haram
durante siete meses el grupo islamista
la convirtió en su califato hasta que el
ejército retomó la ciudad
desde entonces miembros de boko haram se
esconden allí en esa inmensa espesura
que los lugareños llaman con temor el
bosque de zámbiza
el ejercito transformo obama en un super
campamento las calles están atravesadas
por muchos puestos de control y barreras
pero la ciudad en la que el 85% de los
edificios habían sido quemados o dañados
está volviendo a la vida se reconstruyó
el mercado y se restauró el palacio de
jehú el emir tradicional
elche jun que también es un líder
espiritual volvió a fama hace menos de
un año tras seis años de exilio en la
capital del estado de borno maiduguri
[Música]
la mayoría de la gente sigue en
maiduguri porque hasta ahora aunque
pensaban volver no tenían donde alojarse
pero ahora que sus casas fueron
reconstruidas se han empezado a regresar
agradecemos mucho esto con la ayuda de
fondos europeos
la ong mercy corps ha reconstruido
cientos de casas después de cuatro años
en un campo de refugiados
palmat a buscar de 50 años por fin tiene
un hogar
[Música]
merci corts construyó esta habitación
para mí
el único problema es que no tengo nada
que poner aquí pero mis hijos y yo nos
las arreglamos antes de la caída de mamá
palmata era una exitosa mujer de
negocios vendía telas y perfumes por
toda la región pero algunos de sus
vecinos de entonces consideraban que su
trabajo era inapropiado una mujer casada
debe quedarse en casa en ese entonces
boko haram tenía muchos simpatizantes en
la ciudad por lo cual fue denunciada
ante este grupo quien le puso precio a
su cabeza al seguir viajando pero un día
vi cómo ejecutaban gente delante de mí
así que decidí dejar mi trabajo a sabía
que un día llegaría mi turno
cuando la ciudad fue tomada en 2014 su
casa fue completamente quemada y su
marido fue asesinado mientras trataban
de huir dos de sus hermanos murieron a
causa de sus heridas
como resultado ahora fall mata está a
cargo de ocho niños sus cinco hijos y
tres sobrinos que quedaron huérfanos el
ambiente parece tranquilo pero la
antigua empresaria orgullosa de su
independencia en otra época tuvo que
empezar de cero cuando volvimos aquí por
primera vez teníamos miedo pero ahora ya
nos acostumbramos a este barrio lo que
me desespera es que no tengo nada que
hacer excepto hace poco cuando me
contrataron para trabajar limpiando y
barriendo las calles a pesar de los
incentivos de las autoridades no todos
están dispuestos a regresar a las
ciudades liberadas
en la región de borno diez años de
guerra con boko haram han dejado dos
millones de desplazados
[Música]
casi uno de cada dos habitantes
en el campo de vacas y a 70 km de obama
viven 30.000 personas
fátima mikael de 26 años
lleva cinco años viviendo aquí
muchas veces pienso en mi vida de antes
en bahamas
siempre me siento feliz cuando lo hago
bien ahora
el padre de mis hijos y todos sus
hermanos seguían vivos
y todos vivíamos bajo el mismo techo en
armonía
en nochebuena nunca hecho
tiene hasta en el frente
al igual que fall mata fátima también
perdió a su marido y a sus cuñados
cuando obama cayó pero durante su
retirada los rebeldes secuestraron a su
hijo menor hussaín quien tenía dos años
para evitar que acabara como niño
soldado fátima decidió seguir a los
hombres de boko haram hasta su escondite
empezaron por secuestrar a mi niño por
quitarme a mi hijo y en ese momento
estaba de 8 meses con otro hijo
de alguna
en tanto cuidador una bolsa y sin
embargo me era imposible quedarme y
dejar que se llevaran a mi hijo fatal en
la misiva no habría sobrevivido sin el
piso
por eso decidí seguirlos hasta el bosque
de sant visa
en vacas y fátima administra una pequeña
tienda que vende de todo
desde caramelos hasta cepillos de
dientes y bebidas
un lujo comparado con los 15 meses que
pasó en el bosque de sant vida
allí tuvo que dar a luz solar
pero debido a la falta de cuidados su
bebé recién nacido murió a los pocos
meses
para sobrevivir acepto casarse con un
comandante de boko haram
con quien tuvo un hijo
algunas de las mujeres que estaban
conmigo murieron de hambre y otras de
cólera pensé que para salvar a mi hijo
lo mejor sería casarme con uno de ellos
otras mujeres lo habían hecho y les
habían devuelto a sus hijos y además
tenía hambre y estaba sola me obligué a
casarme con uno de ellos
pero poco después su marido de boko
haram fue asesinado fátima aprovechó
entonces para huir con sus dos hijos
2014 el año en que fátima terminó en
manos de boko haram fue también el año
en el que el movimiento se hizo
mundialmente famoso por el secuestro de
cientos de niñas de secundaria en chivos
boko haram significa la educación
occidental es pecado su líder abu bakr
seco empujó a esta secta islámica hacia
la ultraviolencia luego de que el
ejército asesinar a su fundador
también fue él quien juró lealtad al
autodenominado grupo estado islámico en
pero incluso después de que el ejército
recapturar a abama boko haram continúa
atrincherado en el noreste ya que las
frustraciones locales son muy fuertes
allí
en nigeria la región de borno es muy
pobre electoralmente insignificante e
históricamente despreciada por el poder
central
como resultado tras 10 años de intensa
represión por parte del ejército
nigeriano quien según los expertos ha
matado a más civiles que boko haram la
insurgencia sigue viva a pesar de las
divisiones internas
el ejército controla las ciudades que se
han transformado en campamentos
atrincherados boko haram está
multiplicando los ataques a las bases
militares y las extorsiones en el campo
en el campamento de vacas y las
inclusiones de boko haram siguen siendo
una amenaza constante
mis hombros revisan los vehículos y la
gente que entra el campamento si veo que
alguien se acerca lo detectará
usted es un extranjero y si usted es un
criminal también lo detectará y sabré
que usted es de pocos harán nuestro
trabajo es detectar y ex filtrar a los
malos de la sociedad
bubba sale china es miembro de la fuerza
de tarea conjunta civil
milicianos civiles muy activos en la
lucha contra boko haram
ha servido de guía en operaciones
militares
y ha rescatado civiles del bosque de
sant vista
solo ahora las cosas están un poco mejor
el año pasado boko haram intentó entrar
en el campamento y vinieron con una
bomba los revisamos y les impedimos
entrar así que la hicieron explotar en
medio de la gente cerca de la puerta del
campamento
bubacar también vigila a los jóvenes del
muchos de los cuales viven en una
pobreza extrema
sabe que la demanda de justicia social
es una de las razones del éxito de boko
haram en borno
en una familia algunos chicos se unen a
las filas de boko haram solo por la
pobreza o por el dinero
otros son obligados por boko haram a
unirse a ellos
[Música]
si alguien no lo hace lo matan
cuando los atrapamos los militares
entran y se encargan de des
radicalizarlos
ángulos y borrando todo lo que boko
haram les metió en la cabeza
y entonces pueden volver con sus
familias como gente normal
fátima se siente a gusto en vacas
su tienda le da independencia económica
sus hijos van a la escuela en el
campamento y está rodeada de mujeres que
han vivido de experiencias similares
ahora estamos juntas y ya eso es un
cambio pues algunas fueron acogidas por
sus familias y otras fueron rechazadas
por sus seres queridos y algunas ni
siquiera volvieron a verlas
ni la boca ni cuando veo eso siento que
mis problemas no son tan graves
comparados con los suyos
eso me da ganas de quedarme y hacer
nuevos amigos en el campamento las damas
tras subir de boko haram
fátima pasó un mes en uno de los
programas de desradicalización para
demostrar que no era una terrorista
infiltrada
[Música]
pero cuando quiso volver con su familia
sus hermanos la rechazaron
la llamaron mujer de boko haram
no puedo ir a casa
y si estuviera sola sería posible pero
no conmigo
mi familia no quiere verlo nunca y
siempre se sienten asqueados cuando lo
miran lo ven como el hijo de boko haram
y cuando hace alguna tontería mientras
juega con otros niños
no vas a dicen que es porque es hijo de
boko haram y vulgar
[Música]
el reloj
más de ti
en su calor
en bornos
[Música]
fátima se comunica sobre todo por
teléfono con su hijo
hoy cumple 6 años
l
para evitar que fuera estigmatizado en
el campamento lo dejo en casa de una
abuela
[Música]
en borno la insurgencia está destrozando
a muchas familias
a veces un hermano se une a las filas de
boko haram
y otro a las milicias de autodefensa
[Música]
para palmas está la antigua comerciante
de obama los problemas son diferentes su
problema de llegar a fin de mes un reto
diario cuando uno tiene ocho hijos que
alimentar por suerte hoy recogió un
balde de trigo en el campo de refugiados
cercanos
con placas cuba
mi principal problema es la falta de
trabajo si tuviera una tienda podría
ayudar a mis hijos e incluso a otras
personas
para mí lo más importante ahora mismo es
encontrar trabajo
[Música]
a veces nos acostamos con hambre pero
cuando los niños venden los sombreros
que hacen podemos usar el dinero para
comprar comida para tal hacer cosa
a veces intercambiamos un sombrero con
alguien solo para conseguir algo de
comer a holanda la braña y los can de la
maraña que elimina como muchos niños de
aquí los niños de palmas tacos en
sombreros de borno después de la escuela
se tarda hasta un mes en fabricar uno
que puede venderse por cincuenta euros
con una pequeña fortuna
esto es suficiente para pagar los gastos
de escolarización de los niños mayores
un año para palmat a la educación es
vital tanto para garantizar a sus hijos
un futuro mejor
como para vengarse de boko haram
ciani
uno de los efectos inesperados de la
insurgencia es que ha reactivado las
escuelas públicas en borno la escuela a
la que asiste uno de los hijos de palmat
a awana fue renovada recientemente
hoy la nueva directora una mujer fuerte
organiza un partido de fútbol y por
sorpresa el partido es mixto
[Música]
el equipo de las niñas frente al equipo
de los niños aquí todos los niños son
iguales enseñar estos valores requiere
valor
dijo
antes tenía miedo si capturaban a un
maestro a un funcionario le cortaba en
la cabeza lo masacraban lo fusilaban y
bot now
pero ahora ya no tengo miedo porque
estamos rodeados de soldados por casi
todas partes les voy a sharon de tus
suyas y boko haram no podrá entrar en la
ciudad
awana juega de portero
lo cual no es poca cosa
[Aplausos]
boko haram dice que la educación
occidental es prohibida disuaden a la
gente de las zonas rurales pero también
a la gente de las ciudades a todos
aquellos que son analfabetos a los que
no han ido a la escuela
esta gente no sabe la diferencia entre
el bien y el mal
pero debido a la insurgencia todos
terminaron en la capital regional
maiduguri como desplazados internos
y casi todos ellos iban a la escuela
allá casi todos los días ahora la
educación occidental se ha vuelto muy
muy importante
el equipo de las chicas gano
pero mientras defiende su derecho a la
educación
la directora tiene cuidado de no
desatender a los chicos
quiero que los niños y las niñas hagan
todo tipo de actividades porque si uno
muestra que las chicas recibieron más
que los chicos los chicos no vendrán
ni siquiera a la escuela
y no debemos abandonar a los chicos
la directora teme que descuidar a los
niños los conviertan en objetivos
fáciles para los reclutadores de boko
haram
[Música]
aunque por el momento el hijo de fal
mata tiene claramente otras pretensiones
me gusta estudiar creo que será muy útil
en el futuro cuando queramos desarrollar
nuestro gobierno local
pero para que eso ocurra la situación
política debe estabilizarse
y su madre necesita de encontrar trabajo
a veces palmata vuelve al mercado de
telas
solía comprar sus suministros en esta
tienda
tienen a la grava dama cara hogar obama
don ahora que tengo una casa si es
posible me gustaría mucho tener mi
propia tienda para retomar los negocios
como antes
[Música]
palmata sabe que mientras no haya paz en
la región
esto seguirá siendo tan sólo una
esperanza por ahora seguirá limitada a
realizar trabajos con poco futuro
cómo limpiar las calles debajo
[Música]
[Risas]
fátima tampoco puede imaginarse una vida
fuera de este campamento temporal sin
embargo hoy tiene una cita con su
familia que vive al otro lado de
maiduguri
recientemente ha reconstruido una fuerte
relación con su padre
hace poco empecé a cuidar de mi padre de
nuevo porque está enfermo
al principio estaba muy asustado me dijo
querida me dijeron que comes carne
humana ante un archivo que boko haram o
como humanos un atributo que obligaron a
hacer eso también he escuchado que matan
a la gente aquí o hagas el mal eso es lo
que me dijo a mí
sí pero incluso en el pasado nunca me
rechazo y ahora me quiere cerca de
misrata
le gusta tenerme cerca de ella
pero con sus hermanos y hermanas las
relaciones siguen siendo mucho más
tensas
los rebeldes no son buenas personas
cuando se la llevaron empezamos a tener
miedo de ella no sabemos qué fue lo que
aprendió de ellos ni cómo la incluyeron
por eso tenemos miedo
si el campamento de vacas y se cerrará
como lo quiere el gobierno
fátima no tendría a donde ir
a veces pienso en volver al bosque de
sant visa
lo pienso cuando veo el desprecio con el
que la gente me mira a mí y a mi hijo
el hijo que tuve porque lo que ocurrió
sigue sucediendo hoy
ellos lo llaman hijo de boko haram y a
mí me llaman esposa de boca gana gana de
quitar de sí pero cuando lo pienso me
doy cuenta de que es imposible
no puedo y no quiero volver a las
ambiciones
si fuéramos aceptados por la sociedad
si nos des radicalizarán seriamente
saramago como si nos educaron contra el
extremismo radical tanto a hombres como
a mujeres sería diferente
porque algunos hombres se vieron
obligados a tomar las armas
babún y me cuba y casi todas las mujeres
tuvieron que unirse a boko haram en
contra de su voluntad
grabados en su mano pero cuando
volvieron la sociedad se negó a aceptar
la sesión
así se nos recibiera con los brazos
abiertos y nos mostraran que entiende el
dolor que sentimos en nuestra situación
amor a que cambiemos al niño a que algún
día todo sería cosa del pasado
[Música]
tras 11 años de insurgencia y terrorismo
bornos se enfrenta ahora una nueva
calamidad la hambruna
según la onu más de 5 millones de
personas viven bajo la amenaza de hambre
las peores cifras en 4 años esto se debe
en parte a la sequía pero también al
miedo que tienen los agricultores de ir
a los campos en los alrededores de obama
muchos agricultores ya no se atreven a
cultivar sin protección militar
el pasado mes de noviembre de cerca de
bakassi boko haram mató a 76
trabajadores agrícolas que cosechaban
arroz fue la masacre más mortífera de
[Música]
mal al de 70 años estaba allí
nos dijeron que hasta ahora solo habían
estado yendo y viniendo sin hacerle daño
a nadie
y creo que ahora que habían sido
atacados por el ejército se iban a
vengar de nosotros
sus dos hijos agricultores fueron
asesinados
a él los rebeldes le dijeron que le
perdonaban la vida para que pudiera
testificar
el mensaje para el ejército es que la
insurgencia está lejos de ser erradicada
y el mensaje para los civiles es que no
hay piedad para los colaboradores
como muchos agricultores
málaga lee es un musulmán devoto desde
el ataque
él y su esposa se han refugiado en la
oración
creo que el gobierno y los insurgentes
deberían entablar un diálogo para poner
fin a la rebelión y área donde allí con
cora para construir una paz duradera
esa es la única solución porque es
terminar hasta el último insurgente para
conseguir la paz no es la salida
desde el ataque
ni él ni sus vecinos campesinos han
vuelto a los campos
[Música]